[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings that is
casey musgrave's new single it's called
justified it's from her album that just
dropped at midnight it's called
star-crossed and she also released a
film to go with the album on paramount
plus which is a part of viacom cbs
casey stopped by our set at 3 37
yesterday afternoon to tell us all about
it
this is a very different album for you
it is and you said that you were ready
and wanted to put it all out there that
you really wanted to go there and take
us there where do you want to take us i
think i just want to take everybody on
the um the healing journey that i've
been on
and
you know this record for me was about
looking at trying to transform my trauma
my pain into something beautiful one
takeaway i'd love for people to think
about when they hear these songs is like
you know we live in this age where we
log onto social media and we see
everyone's highlight reel you know we
see all the good the shiny the happy and
um you just have to remember that that's
just not it's not reality you know which
leads me to camera roll favorite line
from camera chronological i love camera
roll chronological order ain't nothing
but
torture
your camera roll can be like a really
dangerous place to go we don't have
pictures
hanging out in our pocket in our phones
of all the bad times the awkward times
like the fights the arguments like the
self-doubt we don't have pictures of
that so it's really a skewed version of
our past and if you're in a vulnerable
place it's just it can really mess with
your mind i think breadwinner i read was
something you were reluctant to put on
the album i'm very glad you did i think
a lot of women can relate to this he
wants a breadwinner he wants your
shimmer to make him feel
bigger girl
until he starts feeling this is a word
insecure yeah why were you reluctant to
put that on well i just i don't want any
negative or kind of acerbic emotion to
speak for the whole thing and you know i
think when you hear this record and you
hear the songs you will hear that there
is so much love in them but you can't go
through
a divorce or heartbreak or life change
without feeling the negativity too and i
wanted to honor myself as a creative and
as a songwriter in giving all the the
emotions like the space to breathe so i
think that we all can relate to
you know the bread winner mentality
women i think have been felt like they
need to dim themselves
to not overshadow their guy you know in
a lot of ways did you ever feel you had
to dim your light that's one of my main
messages to women all the time i mean
but that's you know i think that can
happen in friendships
business relationships and i just think
that just don't play it small you know
if you have to shrink yourself to be
around who you're who you're being
around i think you know you might need
to find new people how did you come up
with the title star-crossed it just
popped in my mind like i thought about
all these great tragedies over time
right you know these these love stories
these um
something that we can all you know
relate to and i thought about romeo and
juliet and then i thought about the word
star-crossed and what it means and you
did a movie to go along with it too and
i thought the movie was fun thank you
also very deep there's so so many layers
of um real emotion real experiences
everything that you see there was done
for a reason everything is very
intentional it's a hyper real kind of
fantastical way of portraying this
journey that i've been on through
healing and along the way i mean there's
like there's looks served you know
there's it was really fun it was it was
mostly so fun you know i remember were
we in south africa when you were
performing golden hour yeah you were so
giddy and so happy
and that's where you were at that time
in your life when you look back on it
now does it does that album feel tainted
to you or no not really
for a while i was nervous because you
know i know that a lot of people love
those songs and when they come see you
play you want to give people what they
want to hear and
for a while i was like man that's going
to be so painful for me having to go
back there but ultimately i'm in a
different place in my life now i can say
that i'm happy and i'm kind of looking
in on that other chapter from another
side and i i really don't think that the
magic of that album has to die with
that relationship that inspired it they
said if golden hour was one it was one
side this is the other side after great
shiny beautiful periods a lot of times
come the shadow periods or the night
time and i think that both have to exist
for you to really respect
you know both sides of it or whatever so
again like i wouldn't take anything back
in my life
no i feel like a better person like i
know myself more
through all of this